ben salah les séries vendredi ce sera le
black friday mais on peut déjà profiter
des promotions peu partout d'ailleurs ça
donne parfois des scènes d'émeutes dans
les magasins vous avez vu les connu ces
tirs et l'info du jour c'est que des
députés souhaitent interdire le black
friday qui donne l'impression aux
consommateurs de bénéficier de soldes
alors que ce n'est pas la période
regarder les scènes de koei par exemple
qu'on a vu regardez regardez
[Applaudissements]
jeudi la cohue partout et qui va
profiter du black friday est ce que le
black friday donc qui va être peut-être
interdire est ce que ça vous inspire ou
pas qui inspire qui vous plaît je trouve
ça un peu facile d'être contre une seule
quand on gagne plus de 7000 euros par
mois jacques ces députés qui veulent
interdire
j'aime bien il est sans fil
j'aime bien il annonce est une bonne
idée ben oui non mais non ah non mais
c'est en crise et même si on a
l'illusion
rien que ça ça favorise l'achat et c'est
bien pour la consommation c'est sans
fenêtre ça oui mais simplement pour moi
c'est une bonne idée c'est un espèce de
phénomènes tendance qui est apparu comme
ça ça n'a rien à voir avec les
véritables de sol c'est du snobisme pur
moi je déteste
voilà bon ils ont l'équivalent d'une
maintenance et pas du tout du snobisme
si t'aime pas une émission télé tu
zappes si toi tu vas pas acheter c'est
formidable je ne peux avoir des
ordinateurs à -70%
présenté à cannes par les eaux sur deux
fins de mois mais tu y vas tu cours bien
sûr je ne peux pas être très bête mais
les femmes ont besoin de cette hormone
du bonheur aller faire les magasins
le rôle du bonheur c'est là tout va
alors moi tu connais rien néanmoins du
golfe venues de chine
je venais de sherrie levine chili rausis
y est on est arrivés d'algérie donner
d'autres dodo
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
pourquoi ça s'appelle black
pourquoi prat et des concerts qui n'ont
pas du tout ça une vraie raison parce
qu'en fait c'est le lendemain de
thanksgiving
en fait les commerces les commerces aux
états unis était complètement dans le
rouge du comtal et compta vous savez le
rouge les déficitaires ils ne mettent en
rouge
et quand c'est au crédit il met en noir
ah ouais en fait comme ça marchait pas
du tout vous avez tous les comptes rouge
et grâce au black friday ils sont passés
au noir ça si on ferme ma gueule et on
doit on boit ses paroles
interrogé par le journal la provence
vague mal à la chavez qui va rendre sa
couronne de miss france le 14 décembre
prochain a révélé qu'elle souhaitait
participer à miss monde tout en taclant
le concours concurrent miss univers miss
monde est basée sur des valeurs
humanitaires alors que miss univers est
purement esthétique miss monde c'est
plus une compétition dans l'engagement
et dans la capacité de la candidate à
promouvoir telle ou telle cause elle à
défendre sur la scène médiatique donc
ces attaques qui pourraient blesser
iris mittenaere qui fait la fierté de la
france voilà qui a fait la fierté de la
france en décrochant le titre de miss
univers à ce que ça on s'en fout
actuellement raison parce que dans
l'univers il ya la capacité on est on
peut être complètement bourré de
chirurgie c'était contrairement à miss
monde ce qu'elle revient au vélo c'est
mathieu on s'en fout de ça que cette
chirurgie esthétique passion et éthique
quand tu es beau tu es beau c'est tour
de la c1 et puis pardon miss france ça
reste un concours de miss donc on les
fait défiler pour être belle
alors arrêtez nous par une valeur de 200
nouvelles la caisse est d'accord ou pas
des valeurs façon sais quoi parce que
sur un micro de dire qu'elle ait des
valeurs j'ai pas dans sa chambre à
coucher
ces sois belle et tais toi tu es fils
éviter défi n'était plus loin que ça les
gens choisissent pas pour lequel le
fugitif
ces questions la guerre qu'on est en
crise il ouvrait boukouvala ma banane à
la sciure plaît s'il vous plaît s'il
vous plaît
oui madame et je rappellerai
ultérieurement milieu de semaine
prochaine au début de son mandat elle
l'a ouvert elle était très bien est elle
était drôle a été positive elle était un
peu subversif et là je trouve qu'à la
fin de son mandat elle déconne un peu
elle a dit d'abord qu'elle était
objectif à elle est un objet une femme
objet pendant tout son mandat après se
présente à nice menton déjà elle se
contredit
et là je trouve que voilà les ailes et
pas très élégante à la fin personne à
cacher mais vous dites que vous voulez
c'est bien si vous êtes sorti je connais
des gens qui disent qu'ils n'aiment pas
la lumière elle sa chronique au dedans
si vous le savez tout le monde a charrié
tf1 lorsqu'ils ont voulu que smaïn
parole à revers la singer moi je dis
voilà je vous dis et chouly nommé harry
tim smyczek 6 musiciens qu'on ait eu
enfin je vous lis et elle a même frôlé
hier voilà est franchement c'est vrai il
a été démasqué vendredi dernier c'est
lui qui se cachaient dans le costume du
monstre regardez on va revoir les images
et c'est vrai que smaïn a répondu ouais
walters sur sa page facebook vous allez
nous dire ce que vous en pensez
goode qui va pour son pronostic final
c'est parti je ne sais pas gilles
lellouche florence foresti capable de
faire ça je sais pas par exemple
l'allemand rwe 9 0 jean dujardin
je voudrais dire gérard lanvin cet arrêt
habitants gad elmaleh kad merad manu
payet antoine de caunes pierre niney
françois damiens alain chabat
les daft punk
[Musique]
les jags du one man show car sa manière
une victoire de la musique
à l'égard mathieu ne veux pas ça il n'en
veut pas aux internautes on va voir la
réponse de smaïn juste avant mais c'est
vrai que là le jury le nez vos choix
c'est honteux
alors il a répondu il n'y a pas de
méchanceté gratuite il n'y a que du
débit de sale gueule délit de sale
gueule voilà alors oui ah non alors
c'est un grand c'est un grand grand
artiste mensah j'ai rien à dire les
primes il a fait l'olympia c'est un des
premiers aussi robes à voir ici
justement à percer bien avant que jamais
loupé sa où c'était plus compliqué à
l'époque respect semaine
en revanche si un truc que je déteste
est ce qu'il a fait ça ça me rend fou je
déteste quand on se serre ou quand on
serait sûr une minorité pour se défendre
à aucun moment personne n'a dit que
c'était parce qu'il était rouge bleu ou
quoique y avait pas ce qu'il dit de sale
gueule il laisse entendre que c'est
parce qu'ils les rebeus que qu'on la
critique est sur internet j'ai par la
défense de ce que j'ai lu ce qu'ils ont
dit j'ai lu ce qui a été dit et mine de
rien y'a quelques commentaires très
racistes à l'encontre de ces cahiers
toujours séquence un jour série mais qui
ont pu le blesser lors smile n'avait pas
toute la journée sur les réseaux sociaux
ils dénombrent ne sais pas avec qui
répondait cyril et répondez aux gens qui
lisent est grosso modo on voulait gérard
lanvin jumelles inhalé des fumées alors
c'est donc ses doigts c'est dommage je
jouais une minorité et d'eau mais il
faut que jamais se victimiser qu'une
mérité parce qu'elle est vraie preuve de
raul ou évolué oui il faut pas c'est
tomber là dedans et là j'ai pas aimé ce
qu'il a fait mais tu n'as pas surtout
que ce n'est pas le problème
géraldine dormoy là il ya un débit de
sale gueule sur celle à un débit de
sales gosses sûr lié aux seins d'amy
sale gueule surtout les gens qui ont mis
les jours ils plébiscitent passé j'en
suis absolument d'accord avec avec
mathieu je trouve que du coup il se
victimiser il instrumentalise le truc
pour autant quand il ya samuel el
gueddari et ladji doucouré l'asmo alors
on dira la caudale c'est raciste public
de tf1 est raciste
autrefois ton attention il faut pas sûr
par contre c'est que maintenant j'ai la
carterie moi je le connais un peu il est
très sympathique c'est vrai qu'il est
amour il ya beaucoup de talent mais je
le sais assez intelligent et lucide pour
se douter que les jeunes ne le
connaissent pas il ne veut rien ils
connaissent pas quant aux plus anciens
comme moi j'suis désolé mais nous qui
les monts l'attendait dans autre chose
que je chante en playback dont ceux
tenus par échouer on espérait voir la
fin
olivier chaque instant car il s'agit
d'un grand parti je le lis la bible quoi
en penser dit je vais marais après je
vous le dis ce que reprochent les gens
c'est on a vu là le jury c'est le ji
savent très bien que c'est à jean
dujardin
ça peut très bien que ses habitants non
mais non ben ari bitton s'il aurait pu
faire la limite mais voici les dark et
voilà mais arrivés tôt il aurait pu le
faire mais jean dujardin envoyé jean
dujardin
ouais mais qui laisse pas entendre que
les gens qui ont critiqué son tout
raciste enfin c'est tf1 qui le met en
boule à cette situation en mettant comme
ça parce que c'est vrai qu'en font
aujourd'hui le mec se retourne smaïn on
n'est pas non plus en train de dire
waouh incroyable c'est une star
planétaire
donc c'est plutôt à tf1 qu'il aurait dû
un petit peu chatouiller en disant voilà
vous m'avez mis dans une position à
l'orée du shaq qui se font scheer étant
un cossu bilatérale à mon frère c'est
près de 20000 euros moyennant 20
millions en moyenne
oui j'allais faire le con dans un
costume de 3 cette année mais voilà on
l'a fait déjà dans quoi on l'a fait hier
sur le web et vous l'avez fait
gratuitement oui et après je voudrais
pas un nouvel avis de oui non mais
soyons pas naïfs c'est tout ça c'est des
jeux d'argent le téléspectateur n'est
pas dupe non plus on met des stars de
danse fois que c'est ptet ils ont pris
un chèque
c'est très bien cela était devenu
fataliste ou non non non non mais
semaine un talent incroyable
on l'a reçu dans les années bonheur à
jour il a imité yves montand il est
extraordinaire a vu des séquences et la
vérité c'est un très grand chanteur tu
nous tu nous parles d'un truc louis
moi ce que je regrette c'est clie du
bashing comme ça sur des artistes qui
est un oui énorme carrière est à dire
quand je pense à sheila ou même marie jo
pérec ou imaginent ça c'est pas du
bashing c'est que les gens je te le dis
moi même un peu les internautes 20
fournis clos je te le dis et je le redis
les téléspectateurs sont les berne
à un moment les mecs quand tu leur dis
il va avoir barack obama et vision
durée jean dujardin et tu te retrouves
je les aime beaucoup mais accrocheuse
marie josé pérec l'apprendre mais n'ont
pas tenu et voilà donc tu te dis oui il
faut être garde c'est que si tu te dis
oui on va aller voir l'équipe de france
oui mais bon alors il ya une map et qui
joue par à julie ya pas griezmann mais
par contre ya patrick touche à venir a
dû s'arrêter mon frère oui mais résultat
c'est les artistes qui paye c'est ça que
je veux dire c'est bizarre heureusement
les actrices qui paient pas de leur
faute l'année prochaine vous le dis à
tes pas dans ma singer mettait des
boulangers des plombiers font insistants
mais c'est bref il a bercé mon plombier
raison des coupables c'est
l'organisation tf1 et le sketch du jury
qui ont fait des tonnes
en revanche vincent vous qui avez une
activité aujourd'hui tout marche pour
vous est ce que vous vous iriez danse
mais en fait c'est très compliqué parce
que quand on vous appelle pour entrer
dans un nouveau programme on sait pas
quoi mais maintenant vous l'avez dit
maintenant tu la vérité tirage avait
annoncé que tu vas te faire miroiter
dont les coûts seront bien la vérité
et pense à des ponts le cheikh a tu vas
là-bas mais je fis je serai qu'on va pas
les faire le zazou dans le costume de
l'élégance avec l'état alors que vous
dites mais maintenant c'est dense avec
ma robe pour être très honnête je crois
que je demanderai ce qui est à faire qui
a dans l'émission tu vois ce qui revient
oui mais attendez quelques chansons par
exemple tout ça est ce qu est ce qu on
peut défendre sur scène c'est que les
dires n'y a rien à défendre ton
téléphone et tu vas eurodisney tu mets
un costume c'est l'amérique staff on
peut faire pour s'amuser aussi sur les
gens qui peuplent et peut-être demain
d'argent non mais une envie de se marrer
pense qu'ils vont d'abord à l'oseille
d'abord s'amuser après je peux dire
qu'en tant que canadiens costumes et que
tu chantes comme un roman non mais si
oui c'est vrai les pauvres moi je
c'est une tannée arevalo oui madame ben
ça justifie pas d'être cruel sur les
réseaux
vous avez des quinze-vingts discours ben
voila moi je la plage les plages quand
je peux l'épreuve
il est écouté alors non mais dis comme
moi dit que ses joueurs sachent que les
artistes payent le prix de ce à quoi la
raison de faire que des compliments gros
chèque c'est normal qu'après battu petit
a critiqué aussi pas d'accord pourquoi
on prendre un chèque on se fait
critiquer non c'est vrai bien il ya des
relais du bonheur parce qu'on est
algérien on arrive en est-il main devant
une main derrière
[Applaudissements]